good evening we are the two actors you
keep hearing about but whose names you
have trouble pronouncing actually I have
to come clean my Kemal Nanjiani is my
stage name my actual given Pakistani
name is Chris Pine
so you can imagine how annoyed I was
when the other when the white crisp line
showed up the real Chris Pine
we are also immigrants I'm from Kenya
and I'm from ten years in the house and
I am from Pakistan and Iowa two places
to places that nobody in Hollywood can
find on a map and like everyone in this
room and everyone watching at home we
are dreamers we grew up dreaming of one
day working in the movies dreams are the
foundation of Hollywood and dreams are
the foundation of America and so
[Applause]
to all the dreamers out there we stand
with you
[Applause]
now the nominees for achievement in
production design
Beauty and the Beast production design
by Sarah Greenwood and set decoration by
Katie Spencer
Blade Runner 2049 production designed by
Dennis Gassner and set decoration by
alessandra quit solar darkest hour
production design by Sarah Greenwood and
set decoration by Katie Spencer Dunkirk
production design by Nathan Crowley and
set decoration by Gary ffedith the shape
of water production design by Paul
Denham Oscar berry and set declaration
by Shane vo and Jeffrey a Melvin and the
Oscar goes to the shape of water
[Applause]
nomination for Hall denim Austin
Shane vo and Geoffrey a melting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
first of all thanks to all the Canadian
crew are partying right now Polly are L
in Toronto this is this is for you thank
you to the Academy
Guillermo may you keep dreaming up your
monsters and their wonderful stories so
people like us can help shape their
worlds
thanks a mouse Dale David David Greene
Bob Nancy Utley Matthew Greenfield Ann
everyone Fox Searchlight
please keep making films wonderful films
like this Lewis C Garrett den Lewiston
would not be up here without your
support and not just Churchill and all
the amazing art department and
construction paint crew in Toronto thank
you and my wonderful people right here a
big thank you to our amazing crew back
in Toronto without you guys we
definitely wouldn't be here today thank
you
I share this award with the people who
put me here my wife and kids Sheila Alex
Sarah my co-workers who were inspired by
Gare Mo's vision Avril Alex Angie Carlos
Dominic Toni Jeff Byron Karl Brenton
Nigel William Dave and Dave mark trace
Matthew marina and Donnie thank you so
much for getting this for me